Here we go,
folks,
I know we had some issues.
I know in the past it hasn't always gone
perfectly,
but today we're going to try your
hardest gonna.
Try her hardest to get shit together.
Folks put it together.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book and you
will get 30 free days of audible service
if you have never used audible.com
or heard of them.
It's an excellent resource for audio
books,
perhaps the best on the net and that's a
strong statement,
but I stand by it more than 100,000
different titles.
I'm a great books like our friend Chris
Ryan sex at dawn that's on,
that's available on audible.
You can get that for free if you go to
audible.com,
forward slash Joe.
Uh,
if you don't use audio books,
you're a silly bitch because they're
awesome.
It's great if you have to travel.
If you get stuck in traffic,
if you're sitting on a bus,
it's.
It's an an amazing thing that can take
an otherwise wasted moment in time and
actually make it enjoyable and make,
make it educational.
Only enrich yourself while you're on the
bus.
Bitch.
Get it together and if you go to
audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get it together for free for 30
bucks or for 30 days rather than 30 days
for free audio service and one free
audio book.
Go try it,
check it out.
We are also brought to you by hover.
Hover is a domain name company that's
owned by the same people that own Tang
and if you know how how gushy Lovey we
are at a 10,
you know that we feel the same way
about.
Hover the idea behind ting.
What I love about it is that they're
trying to give you a great deal on
excellent service and they're trying to
make things as sort of as easy and
ethical is as simple and fair as
possible and that same sort of attitude
is taken up by hover.
They try to provide you with things for
free,
that other domain name companies will
make you charge for it.
Like who is domain name privacy?
Um,
if you go to hover.com
forward slash rogen,
you will get 10 percent off your domain
name registrations.
I actually have domains registered
through hover.
Um,
uh,
I got a bunch of them that I'll probably
never use,
but I had an idea.
I can't tell you right now,
man,
I can't tell you I had a project in
mind.
Um,
but,
uh,
but you know what,
I don't have kids and projects.
I started them up and then I go,
shit,
what the fuck am I doing with this?
The weed silly website idea.
But if you wanted to register a website,
I mean I obviously run actual.
I mean I have Joe Rogan.net
and there's other websites,
but if you want to start your own
hovers,
where'd it go?
Go check it out.
And uh,
I believe you get a free domain name
registration if you sign up for more
than a year,
right?
Isn't it?
Something like that.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an awesome company.
So go check it out.
Hover dot forward slash rogen.
Go there,
save some money.
Uh,
we are also about to buys edit.
No,
we have one more,
right?
Oh,
stamps.com
stamps.com.
Which,
uh,
if you,
if you've ever seen those silly desk
squad kittycat tee shirts that brian red
band creates,
and if you haven't seen them go to
[inaudible] dot TV there,
they're pretty bad ass.
And uh,
especially the hypnotic looking one
psycho psychedelic cat.
I love that little fucker.
But uh,
Brian sends all that stuff through
stamps.com.
If you are a,
someone who runs her own business,
go into the post office can be a real
pain in the ass.
It's a long wait in line to deal with
some unenthusiastic person that doesn't
really want to weigh your shit and tell
you how much it costs.
A huge trend.
There's like there's people waiting
behind.
You were like,
really?
You're,
you're bringing boxes of shit in here.
You can actually do all this stuff right
from your desk.
You have to do is go to stamps.com
and check out how it works.
You buy.
And print an actual official us postage
for any letter or package using your own
computer and printer.
I mean it's an amazing thing.
They send you a digital scale and
calculates exact postage.
There's a little microphone.
If you go to stamps.com,
there's a little microphone in the upper
corner.
If you click on it and enter the Promo
Code J R,
e Dot,
you will get a $110 bonus offer which
includes a digital scale and up to $55
of free postage.
It's an excellent service folks.
And again,
if you run a business and you don't use
stamps.com,
you're really being silly because it's.
It will make your life so much more
simple.
If you have to dread those treks to the
post office.
I'm sure.
I'm sure that scale will be good for
weighing out tobacco to how dare you.
How dare you in the middle of the
stamps.com.
And if you don't think you're really
talking about tobacco,
I do not believe you.
Listen,
we ain't no way endorse selling illegal
tobacco and then shipping it using
stamps.com.
That is not what stamps.com
was for.
Okay.
Stamped out skits for flags.
If you're selling American flags,
if you've got maybe ammo that needs to
be shipped legally.
State to state.
Yes.
Go to stamps.com,
but please no illegal tobacco in the
Canadian.
Pretty bad at scale right there.
That was all right.
It was.
All right.
Ladies and gentlemen,
just go there.
The code has jre.
Use it.
Stamps.com.
It's fucking awesome.
Go check it out.
That stamps.com
at the top of the homepage.
Enter J R,
e,
enjoy.
Relax,
repeat.
Rinse.
Douglas.
Rushkoff is here.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Cue The music.
Okay.
Do you know how to do it?
It's kind of got too much tobacco in it.
Experience
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Too Loud,
right?
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
The.
We have an adjustment thing here.
It's too loud.
We can actually lower your volume.
Where you at?
Are you this one right here?
Is that better?
Is that better for you?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Sorry about that.
Didn't mean to blow your ears off.
Thanks for joining us.
Thanks for Douglas Rushkoff.
If you do not know of him,
hat is a,
what'd you call yourself?
A media analyst.
Which a theorist immediate Arthur.
Mainly author mainly.
Yeah.
And your new book is called present
shock when everything happens all at
once,
is that everything happens now.
And then when everything happens now I
saw quite a few of your videos online.
It really,
really,
really interesting conversations and one
of them that really struck me was,
um,
you know,
several of them that struck me,
but one of them was your story of being
mugged and you,
you told people on an online room like
where you got mugged and people were
upset that you in telling them that you
got,
didn't telling the world that you got
mugged there.
It was lowering their property values.
Yeah.
That was a bad one.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean it was one thing to get mugged.
It was just kind of freaky in itself,
you know,
and whatever shaman weirdness goes with
that.
But,
um,
I guess what I was trying to do,
I mean deep down was probably elicit,
you know,
love and affection from people on my
list.
You know,
so I put up,
oh you know,
and there was a social,
something social responsibility to it.
So I put up where I got mugged because
everyone should know this is maybe a
dangerous stretch here.
We got to maybe get a light.
But um,
yeah,
so I sent,
I sent it out and then um,
the first two emails I got back from
this loving list of parents was how dare
you see exactly where it happened.
You know,
we live right across the street,
you know,
what you're going to lower our property
values.
Are you selling now?
Is that,
is that.
No,
we're not selling.
But it was a really weird time when
people needed their property values to
go up because they were trying to get
bigger mortgages and pay down and do all
that.
And it was just like so panicky there
about that,
that some,
you know,
someone was afraid of what if a
newspaper covers it and it's bad and
it's so weird when one's and zero's
trump humanity,
you know?
And in that case,
that's exactly what that is.
It's ones and Zeros,
trump,
humanity.
Well yeah,
in two kinds of ones and Zeros,
you know,
the ones and zeroes,
that money now and the ones and the
startup of digital technology,
which I think can create a kind of a
distance that feeling the impact of
saying that to someone's face here.
Yeah.
There's a weird communication that takes
place online.
That's you.
It doesn't have any consequence,
you know,
you can,
you can do it anonymously and there's
just like these barbs that you can just
send out and illogically like in,
in,
in ways that you would never.
If you had to deal with someone one on
one because you would feel it,
you would look at that.
You would feel the response,
you would be like,
why are you saying this?
Like,
like why?
Why are you being such an asshole?
But because you are anonymous,
so people are just like in this
unnatural communication thing.
Right?
But then the part that worries me after
that is if you get used to doing it like
that in an anonymous way online,
just to start to make the behavior a bit
more normative when you're even with
your identity.
Oh,
I guarantee it has to.
It has to.
There's,
there's no free rides when it comes to
that.
I,
I really feel like your thoughts,
you're kind like,
there was always a thing.
I remember when I was in high school,
this was someone in my school newspaper
wrote like a funny critique about the
boy scouts and one of the things that he
didn't like about the boy scouts was
that they wanted you to keep your
thoughts pure.
I,
he was like,
you know,
well my thoughts are my own thoughts,
as long as I don't do anything,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with my thoughts.
Right.
And that was really smartly argued.
I remember reading that going,
wow,
this kid's pretty clever.
But then I thought about,
I'm like,
but you,
if you're thinking about creepy shit,
you probably are kind of creepy,
you know,
and it's not going to get any better.
Just,
you know,
you're just gonna eventually one day
going to snap and then going to do
something.
Maybe thing.
Yeah.
If you really are like the,
I don't know.
I mean everyone has their own definition
of thoughts being pure,
you know,
like a more lenient person might allow a
lot of healthy sexual things and the
idea of thoughts being pure as long as
it's not creeping.
But there's other people that would just
sit around and say,
well,
let me just think about creepy shit all
day and not do it and I'm fine,
but there's no free ride.
There may be though you think.
Well,
I mean what you're describing like
you're describing is you know,
the benefits of an absolute police state
as long as it was always right.
No,
that's no problem.
You know,
that's the problem.
I mean,
you can always get your,
my narrative report,
you know,
just maybe they're running really
subscribing that.
I'm just saying that you've been,
you can't have really shitty thoughts
and get through.
And I think that if you're really shitty
online,
if you have those thoughts,
even if it's only online,
I really believe that negative energy
genuinely shitty.
I mean it's just how do you decide
what's,
what's shitty and whatnot.
But yeah,
now it's people when their demeanor you
are online without your face,
the meaning you can be online with your
face on the meaning you can get in real
life until you just got mean people.
Do you investigate pupils to it?
Like if someone sends you something
weird on twitter,
do you go to their twitter page and see
just all their country shit that they
write to everybody and go,
oh,
they're just crazy guy.
I will admit I focus way more on the
content tweets and emails and things and
on the ones that are 10 emails.
Oh,
your book was great.
I love it.
You've changed my life.
My children worship at your altar.
He was like,
delete,
delete.
With this guy.
Yes,
this is the biggest piece of Shit I've
ever read,
but I need 10,000
people.
Loved it more than life itself,
but I'll spend the rest of my week
trying to convince this one guy.
Oh No,
you don't.
I am not a bad guy.
Why?
The book is actually okay.
You gotta learn the Internet well now.
Well,
it's inevitable.
It's hard.
It's hard not to engage people because
they're like a person saying it to you.
It's very similar and to have someone
who's public,
you know you're out there,
you have your,
your name is out there in the videos are
out there.
Anyone can find out about you and see
you.
They can reach you to and reaching you
on twitter.
You know,
they can send you some shitty thing just
to get a arise from you and then they're
just making you dance and you're dancing
dancing's to someone else's spell.
So you've got to learn how to just look
at yourself and go,
does this make sense?
And be able to leave it,
but you've got to be able to do that to
the point where where it's healthy and
not beyond.
Yes.
At some point,
if everybody's going to wake up,
your bug needs to be this.
When it's,
you know,
you've got,
you can do this,
but you can't do that.
I,
well,
in the end of the sale,
the market would tell me.
I guess the market will tell you,
but you're not a dumb guy.
You'd never do that.
Never make a book like that.
That was so often out of line.
You would look at yourself along the way
down.
I can tell him talking to you for 10
minutes.
You're not that Kinda guy,
but the kind of guy that would do that,
it's like there's certain people that
are functional,
crazy and they can like figure some
things out and chase some things down
and then they'll get stuck in some sort
of a weird Rut and you can't talk them
out of it and you know,
you realize,
oh,
he was crazy all the time.
He just figured out how to get through
life.
You know?
Those are the ones that will go off on
crazy tangents and people go,
what are you doing?
Because the guy wasn't really nuts in
the first place.
You're not nuts,
man.
You don't have to worry about that.
Just need to keep people around you to
keep telling you you're not insane.
I can.
I think there's a good thing that comes
from criticism though,
because it's even really harsh criticism
is because if they're ridiculous and if
you look at what they're saying,
if it's ridiculous and mean and it
really reveals far more about them than
it really does about you,
but look at what they're saying and is
there any merit to it at all?
Does it make any sense or is it just
nonsense?
It's just a guy being an asshole or if
you weren't,
you could you find merit in it?
Like I've found criticism from the
biggest assholes,
but it was like there was like a hair of
accuracy into it.
It made me reconsider certain things.
I mean,
in the most valuable thing about it.
For me,
it's entertaining.
It to some extent is just.
It makes me,
it makes me more flexible.
You know,
as a,
as a thinker,
you know,
if you can wrap your head around,
Oh,
where am I wrong?
It can make you a little indecisive
because it's like,
well,
he's right and he's also write this,
but sometimes things are complicated.
I know,
but that's the whole.
That's,
you know,
for me,
the object of the game,
that's why I keep writing.
I'm writing about that now,
present,
being present.
If you're actually present,
you have to be present with yourself and
be president who you're with and that's
the thing that everybody looks to be
avoiding one way or another,
you know,
whether,
whether they're doing it cold because I
got to earn money or they're doing it
because they got to check a device.
I mean there's the constant assessing
and it's just.
I see so few people.
I walk into rooms now and I feel like I
don't feel like I'm in a room with these
people.
There's no sort of social cohesion in.
They're not really present.
They're each in their own little
segment,
you know,
connected with the internet or friends.
Yeah.
And then not connected with,
with each other.
You know,
I,
I am,
you know,
I'm a net fan.
I've been since the late eighties.
I've been,
you know,
pro bling bling or cyberpunk type
person.
But,
you know,
I keep feeling like rather than using
these things to,
to reach out to other people and
connect,
you know,
we're using these things for business.
They've gotten super aggressive,
behavior's gotten way worse.
And I don't even think it's our fault.
I honestly think it's in these cases,
it's because we're living on this,
this,
uh,
an operating system,
but an economic operating system that
just needs to feed off the net when
it's,
should be our space,
not the economy space.
Yeah.
It's,
I,
I feel like we're in a stage of
progression for this interconnectivity
progression where we're starting off
with,
you know,
we were starting off with just regular
telephones and that is moved to cellular
phones,
which everybody carries,
which is going to move into some google
glasses type thing which is going to
eventually,
I mean,
down the line,
if you extrapolate 100 years or whatever
it's going to take.
There's gonna be some really crazy
interconnectivity that people share.
And I think this stage that we're going
through right now,
the anonymous stage of being able to
like make a twitter account or some fake
name and just start saying mean things
to random people like that ability is
going to go away.
You're not going to have this anonymous
portal like I,
I just think if you look at the way
things,
I feel like the way I look at the
future,
it's like the thing that's going to be
really scarce is secrets.
I think we're going to be able to
connect with each other in some way that
we probably can't even imagine right
now.
Whether it's some neuro chip or
something that you embed in your body,
whether it's nanotechnology,
whatever it is.
There's gonna come a day where we're
like completely
each other.
But the beauty of that though is if it
really worked,
it would bring us back to the now that
we've been avoiding all this time with a
face to face live interaction where you
can't fuck with each other because
you're here.
You know there's this guy,
strange way to look at it.
Yeah,
I met this guy,
this show guy,
I'm a stage magician guy who could tell
when people are lying.
I don't know if you've ever seen this
guy.
He's like worked for the FBI and stuff
and he can like,
he does all these tricks.
He lines up 10 people and he says,
okay,
one of you think and he,
he can really tell period when people go
online and I was thinking if he can tell
that people are lying because he's got
this talent,
it means that on some level we all know
we all have that ability,
right?
So we all on some level know when the
other one's lying to us.
So it's kind of been,
if you're actually in the moment,
it's all exposed anyway.
Yeah,
I think there's a weird feeling that you
get when someone's being deceptive.
There's a weird feeling you get where
you're like,
there's a sense of disturbance when
you're communicating with them,
you this,
but you can't put it into tangible.
There's nothing you could say,
oh,
it was x amount of weight.
So here I know this is a real thing.
You know,
here,
I'll put it on a scale,
it's,
but there's some weird thing that
happens when you,
when you're with someone,
like you can tell if someone's upset at
you and not saying it.
They can be saying all the right words,
but you're like,
there's a certain,
there's a coldness or a lack of warmth
or there's a little something I wrote
about the women in a.
what's it called?
The housewives of Orange County.
I got obsessed with them because they
were just having all of these awful
disagreements all the time.
They,
the communications guy.
I'm trying to figure out what,
why is there communication breaking down
and so this is what I do.
So I know.
So I concluded in the end that is
because they've put so much botox in
their faces that they can't actually
execute facial expressions in an honest
way anymore in a way that the other
person organically can react to.
My God.
These women in trying to kind of freeze
time at age 29 ended up making
themselves inaccessible to the now that
they're in,
because you know,
you see one,
they'll say,
oh,
you know,
my,
my daughter,
I think she might have cancer,
and the other one like,
oh,
I haven't been in a smile.
Right?
So then we go to the first.
She said,
I can't believe I told her my daughter
has cancer.
And the other one she says she's sorry,
but I can tell she's not of.
I mean that's just a metaphor,
but that's true.
They're like stuffing cotton in their
mouth and they can't.
You can't understand what they're saying
right there.
They're ruining the facial communication
expressions of facial communication is
we live in the woods shooting poison in
their face to freeze it,
but they're to freeze it in time is that
they're trying to stop time and that's
like A.
I understand the urge to stop time,
but when you stop time,
you lose the moment.
That's kind of the whole point.
I'm making second the net.
It can stop time in a certain way,
but you're going to lose certain moments
that you know,
so I'm all for being on the net and
having a net moment,
but you know,
even here,
you know,
I've heard you do those ads before for
those sponsors and you could just cut
and paste,
you know,
you could cycle seven of them and maybe
people wouldn't even know.
It's the same ones.
You know,
you could cut and paste from another
show and throw it in.
But you decide,
no,
I'm actually going to sit here and read
these three ads with my friends.
Well,
if I didn't do that,
I'd be really bored.
I never want to just read an ad.
So we always do it that
way.
We've always money you make.
And the model of the industrial age of
course is to make print out more.
Yeah.
And the only way we would,
the only way we could even do any of
this stuff,
the way we're doing this because we
don't have anybody that we have to
approve it with.
You know,
knowing that I don't have to go to NBC
and say,
Hey,
this is what we're thinking of doing.
I know you have these commercials but
we're just going to talk shit and
occasionally we'll get to the point of
the commercial,
but,
but ironically on the long run it ends
up making more money,
certainly more money for the people who
are actually doing it.
You know,
maybe by the other system you can make
more total money,
but it's going to go to,
you know,
God knows what does that mean
institution.
Anyway,
so,
so the fact that it is that it is live
and it is a what an MP3.
Mainly it is mainly a podcast you think
on the first hand,
because I'm looking to do make her kind
of radio choice myself and it's like,
well I can do this for the man and make
this amount of money kind of guaranteed,
but I'm going to have to stay between
these site lines and I can go to this
other road and actually do the thing I
do.
You know,
there's not even a choice.
They're not in this day and age.
It's not necessarily,
it's they used to be a time where you
would have to choose,
well,
this internet thing,
who knows if it's gonna work out,
but that's crazy like you,
you have an option to immediately jump
in and get a gigantic group of people
that are going to start retweaking and
tweeting and listening to your stuff and
you'll,
you'll develop a giant following in no
time.
And as that's happening,
all you're doing is you're selling ads
for companies that you actually believe
in.
You.
You could.
That's the only way you should do it.
Fuck working for some company that tells
you not to swear or not to do this or
not to discuss that or you know,
that's not the stance we're taking on is
particularly complicated issue.
No,
fuck that.
That's the enemy of real thought.
The enemy of real thought,
his committee,
you know,
I don't know what you're really
thinking.
Everything you say has to go through a
committee before it comes out of your
mouth.
I want to know what the fuck you're
thinking.
And,
and especially in,
in the sense of a radio show,
you know,
guy on the radio,
that's the whole thing.
It used to be like,
even Djs,
they used to be,
this Dj likes this music,
so this sauce or broadcasting from the
same city,
that urn,
that clear channel took over and it was
like,
oh my gosh,
we're getting a recording that's done by
computer miles away.
This is my local rock and roll stations
goes Jack Fms,
which is essentially like playing
shuffle when you're on your ipad.
Just,
you know,
it could be anything of a number of
things that they approve and they
pretend we're wacky.
We just don't have any rules.
Like,
Oh,
we're Jack FM and that's like a standard
model.
There's like 100 Jack's across the
country and probably even more than
that.
It's weird.
I think radio's completely on its way
out.
I think they're fucked.
I think that's like a,
it's a silly way to do it and no one's
going to stick with it after a while.
Like why you're going to have Internet
access in your car within no time.
That's a,
that's easy.
They could do that right now I already
get that with podcasts on the iphone
because I have my iphone bluetooth to my
car,
so I'll just immediately say,
oh,
I'd like to listen to a Duncan trussell
podcast and inner.
I've done it at a red light where it's
so easy at a red light.
It's one to Dunkin donuts.
Boom.
There is the one aspect of radio that I
feel like I would miss.
Is that local terrestrial,
the reality of it,
I guess.
I mean,
yeah,
we could still have,
I,
you know,
you can have an,
a la channel and I could have a,
you know,
this part in New York channel and you
know,
we could do that technically with
digital,
you know,
where you'd pick your,
your so called regional thing.
It'll be local stuff,
but the medium is not biased towards
that.
The medium is,
it's all equivalent,
you know,
and I wonder would we drift further away
from,
from local and kind of the things that
matter to us in the here and now or um,
you know,
will we choose that stuff?
I think,
you know,
instead of like a local radio station,
you're going to have a million people in
la making their own music,
making their own,
putting their own shit out there that
you can choose from,
you know,
whether it's a music list,
like a Pandora list or something like
that someone puts together or whether
it's podcasting.
I just think the idea of a local
representative was always gross and it
was always grows wolf man.
Jack was always gross because for every
Wolf Man Jack,
there's a million other dudes.
It probably had interesting ideas as
well and they had no outlet.
So you have one guy has this outlet from
this particular time.
That's crazy that that idea sucks.
The I,
the idea that we're dealing with now is
way better.
It's like a billion outlet,
6 billion outlets and,
and there's no local anymore.
There's people that are in that town
that'll tell you about things,
but everyone's more connected than ever
before.
And because they are,
I mean the economy as we know,
it also has to go away to,
you know,
they're 26 billion people doing
podcasts.
I mean,
you've got 2 billion left doing farming.
It's like,
did all the businesses go and you also
lose those iconic figures like the wolf
man Jack or like Howard stern or like
the mate?
Well,
I mean,
I think you could still choose.
You would just have major every once in
a while something major would happen.
Right.
But it wasn't,
it wouldn't be,
wouldn't be that one guy who's your
town's Guy.
You know,
when I grew up in Boston,
it was Charles Laquidara,
Charles Laquidara.
And the big mattress was like this.
He would call this morning show.
It's called the big mattress.
It was a great guy.
Lockwood era.
Really Nice Guy.
Met Him to eventually put he,
um,
he,
his,
he was like the number one radio DJ in
Boston.
Everybody knew it.
You would go to,
when I was doing construction and go to
job sites,
people would turn up or turn on the big
mattress,
listen to Lockwood era.
And it was,
that was a show.
It was like that was shell.
And the only
way to get a show like that,
it's,
and not have a lot of options.
You know,
to have a show that everybody agrees
we're all gonna listen to,
you know,
it's kind of the only like three
options.
No disco,
no,
we're not listening to this go,
you know,
there wasn't like the Internet quality
options that,
that,
that changes the whole game.
Like there's never going to be a CBS
radio on the Internet and it does.
It will.
And it's going to replace everything
terrestrial,
I mean on every sense.
So if you're saying,
we're saying everything's going to be
replaced,
everything terrestrials going to be
replaced first it's radio,
then it's other stuff.
All we have to make sure then is before
we lose all those things,
which we're going to inevitably lose to
say to ourselves,
what is,
what is it we value about those things
that we want to bring into these digital
things before we're untethered in there.
You know,
before it's all the way.
Yeah.
Well we want our cake and we want to eat
it too.
We want the digital era and we still
want mom and pop stores.
We're trying to like keep it all
together.
And that's the question is can you get
both,
you know,
so can you have this,
very traditional narrative,
20th century industrial age culture live
right aside,
you know,
this sort of steady state economy and
peer to peer currencies and local CSA as
you know,
can we have an iphone and organic chard
and no slavery in Africa to get either.
Yeah.
Is that possible open?
So we moved towards it or not,
you know,
it seems like that's what a great
percentage of the world would like.
But it's,
we've made shackling little progress and
moving towards that potentially utopia.
Right.
But then,
but you know,
as long as we got a hope or try to
envision that would say okay,
but,
but this shift that we're undergoing now
from an analog era to a digital one is a
bigger shift than just than just that
there's a whole different digital media
environment that we've gone into.
So we've gone into this from this.
This time is money expansionist economy
live by the clock universe to one that's
potentially asynchronous.
That's just off that off that day.
I remember when the net first came up,
it was like,
it was,
you know,
people in Austin and slackers and cyber
punks.
The idea was that the net was going to
give us more slack,
you know,
and it's ended up for most people kind
of doing the opposite because they're
always on and working and being
monitored and all that and distracted.
But I mean,
I think if we,
if we,
uh,
take command of the way we're
programming these things,
then we can use them to sort of,
to create,
you know,
the gorgeous culture,
slack to create,
you know,
what a few of us are,
are kind of discovering we can do like
you're doing with this,
right?
You're just doing your thing.
Yeah.
I think we're trying to resist the
inevitable and that inevitable is the
symbiotic computer relationship.
There's going to be some sort of bio
mechanical connections as when men
talking to another man with that funds
to a million people listening in their
car or wherever the fuck they are
asynchronous.
I really don't feel like we can stop
that.
It seems like the things that we got so
excited by as as these higher
functioning primates are these new
things that we've created that input us
or give us input in a way that our
bodies completely not designed to to get
like through your ear phones,
like like listening to a podcast like
the computer itself,
the ability to watch a video,
the ability to go to the movies.
It's all good.
This is the stimuli that's coming at us.
It's just we're not designed for it,
but it's.
But it's.
It's reconfiguring itself to be as
seductive as possible.
Well,
because it's not what it's for,
right?
It's to seduce us into itself so that
the companies behind it can make money
and because we moved constantly in to in
a path of progression,
and if you look at the technology,
it's always going to move into a
stronger grip.
We were never satisfied with any
particular result at any particular
time.
More choices.
Yeah.
We want more choices.
We want it to be powerful more fast.
We want,
we want better graphics,
we want bigger boobs.
That's not realistic enough.
Let's take it to the next level.
It's,
it's in this desire to get these
experiences were pushing the technology.
Like ultimately that's what's getting.
What's interesting to me about that is
while all that's pushing ahead,
what we get in a digital media
environment is we ended up retrieving
weird medieval values.
You know,
you get burning man and etsy and people
doing peer to peer stuff,
trying to have their local currencies,
which they haven't had since medieval
times.
You know,
you see the stuff that gets her
treatment,
paganism,
men and uh,
you know,
mashing up a route to heal yourself of
things,
maker culture.
All these things are what we've lost
over the last thousand years.
That's what the renaissance and the
industrial age was about.
You know,
stamping that out and putting everybody
on the,
on the assembly line at Ford.
So it's fun that as we move forward,
we get these great old recurrences,
which to me is reassuring.
It means that we are bringing something
with us into,
into this next place.
I think it's also that the current
system is so flawed that people are
willing to try anything and that they're
actually actively thinking about what
can we do differently?
Can we make a local local currency?
Like you got to know him,
which is interesting because like the
two places I've gotten emails from him
the last many years of people doing
social currency,
sorry,
either from a place like Ithaca,
New York where they're doing it because
they're just,
you know,
strange and trying to try something
weird and good.
Or like Lansing Michigan where there's
no GM plant,
there's no bank that's going to give
money to a factory to open up to hire
people and they're desperate.
They're like,
well,
I've got skills.
I know how to fix a fridgerator and they
have needs,
so can't we just make an economy that
way?
You know,
those are the places where people are
actually asking the,
the,
the where they're ready.
I just don't like that.
Readiness seems to involve being just so
I'm not just fed up but uncomfortable.
You know,
that you've got to do something.
Yeah.
We're clearly going through change.
We're clearly going through a change as
a culture that we weren't prepared for
and we're sort of making our way as we
go along and there's a lot of mistakes
along the way and the evidence that
points to it.
One of the best pieces as your story
about people getting upset at you
because you got mugged and called in the
story and said the location.
That's one of the best examples of
people like losing the script like along
the way in this crazy thing that we're
doing where we developed currency and
and then there's things called property
values and those mortgages and equity
and all this crazy shit along the way.
You know,
we're going to have to figure out how
to,
how to stay human and when you see like
instant failure,
like,
oh my God,
I got mugged.
You fucking asshole.
What are you?
Why'd you say the place?
It's interesting.
I made it in every single one of my
books and I've written like 12 now.
You know,
they're,
they're all finally about how do we
bring humanity into this thing that
seems to have lost it.
So I did it for,
you know,
for,
for business,
I did it for,
for the economy with Life Inc is the
book you're talking about did it for
Judaism,
something called nothing sacred.
St Judaism should be this ongoing
conversation.
Keep it alive,
keep it human,
don't let it lock down.
And now this one,
it's weird because it's like I'm kind of
admitting that it's what I guess I'm
realized it myself,
but I'm kind of saying,
oh my gosh,
I'm a humanist.
No,
I'm a humanist and a technology
enthusiast hadn't how do you be both
because so many of the other folks who
are sort of pro technology,
sort of my posse and they're all sort of
talking about not human beings being
enabled by technology but technology
surpassing us,
you know,
some singularity or you know,
some,
some moment in the future where
computers get smarter than us and then
we're not really needed anymore.
It might not be that simple.
I'm a,
I've been thinking about it a lot lately
and one of the things I think is why do
we have this idea of competition and why
would the computer enjoy that idea with
us?
Our idea is based entirely on our
biological makeup,
our need to reproduce or need to prove
ourselves to our mate or need to protect
against strangers.
All these instincts that a computer's
not going to have at home.
So the idea of competition with humans
for resources or the even the idea that
survival is imperative and that you
know,
you,
you have an ego and you can't die,
they're not going to have any of that.
So why would they be in competition with
us?
Why wouldn't it just be like any new?
It wouldn't be because of them.
It'd be because of the program.
The program
though that that's really wouldn't do
the bad thing.
Okay.
So why not keep us around,
but it doesn't matter.
I don't even not.
It's not a matter of them being able to
do that because I don't even think they
will.
I don't think they can.
It's more a matter of people in the here
and now saying that human beings are
really only important insofar as we can
be the shepherds and organizers of
information.
Information is the thing that's evolving
towards greater states of complexity and
once human beings are no longer the best
at making complex information,
but computers are the best at it,
then there's just no need for humans
anymore with the computers kill us or
not.
I don't know what they give us a good
time,
who knows?
But,
but the,
just the whole idea that we should be
developing technology with this in mind.
Um,
I dunno it,
it negates what I think is an essential
for us anyway,
centrality of humanity in the equation.
While I think people don't recognize how
much we need each other,
we don't recognize how important
positive interaction is with other
people to your health and the way you
feel about life.
There's clearly a relationship that
people have to each other that were in
denial about the lock ourselves up in
our apartments or our homes.
And we shut our car doors and we rolled
down the window and that's one of the
reasons why people are willing to give
people the finger when they're in the
car.
He would never do that in real life.
You feel like you're in some sort of a
contained world and even though you're
not even anonymous,
who still like,
fuck you,
you know how many people do give the fan
in real life?
Like nobody.
But once a year I'll give somebody the
finger.
Somebody does something crazy and they
beep at me.
Fuck you.
It's beautiful.
It's a beautiful thing to do.
But you know that eventually I think we
have to accept the fact that we were
only happy when the people around us are
happy,
when we're in harmony with the people
around us were not happy.
When we're in conflict,
we're not happy.
When,
when we're not happy,
when we fuck people over.
Like I know people that have done bad
things in business and bad things
ethically and bad,
you know?
And they're not happy.
No.
But then in the current culture they can
compensate for that with medicine.
Say that type of presence that gets them
through the night,
like you have to hope.
I mean,
I always do,
which is to vain hope.
I hope that the people who do bad stuff
but then make up for it with drugs still
feel worse than I do.
Not taking those drugs and trying to do
good stuff and you don't want to believe
that,
you know,
these kind of guys I used to see,
um,
I won't even say his name,
one of those millionaires down at Knicks
Games and I had always think,
I sure hope he's not happy.
That's fine,
isn't very fair.
But a while hold he's doing is playing
some really crazy game that was around
before he was ever born.
He just got into it and got really good
at it.
The game itself,
it's bananas,
just the stock market itself.
Just the idea that the wealth of,
of,
of a person can vary day by
day because of confidence,
you know,
confidence,
computer,
consumer confidence in a product can
shift and change with recall.
And then watching these numbers go up
and down like what the fuck are you even
talking about?
Most of the explanations you see,
you know,
I watched these business sites and the
market will go down and they say,
oh mark it down because of such and such
in London.
And then it's like,
by the time that piece comes out that
markets actually back up and they're
already constructing their,
you know,
let's tie market going back up to
another random feature.
You know,
it's like the,
the,
the explanations after the fact to have
so little to do with whatever.
Some algorithm decided it was going to
suddenly ultra fast trade something and
throw the stock up.
You know,
it's like at this point it's,
it truly is.
That's the best place to see humans
combating machines on the market where
it's like there's human traders
competing with these programmed
algorithms and the algorithms are
certainly winning the war.
And if you look at their screens while
they're,
while they're doing it,
it is almost like code.
Like the average person who doesn't
understand it,
doesn't know what the fuck the stock
market saying the symbols.
And the essay,
Oh,
and this and that and the ones and the
Zeros.
You look at all that,
you have no idea what that is.
I mean,
how is that really different than a
computer code that you're reading me
that's essentially like a,
a way that people are,
are,
are tapping into this bizarre system.
I mean it was at one time the sort of
the price of something had to do with
some thing.
It's like there's a factory,
oh it's factory went slower today in the
rain.
The market will go down on that.
It was like real,
you know?
And I think it's gotten certainly
further and further from whatever is
going on in that company or their
earnings are the things,
you know,
it's,
it's absolutely abstracted to the point
now where people don't even invest in
companies,
right?
You invest in something like when
facebook went public,
people bought it at like nine in the
morning at like nine,
10.
They're all pissed off that it hasn't
gone up.
It's like,
wait a minute,
I was supposed to my well my wealth.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't make money on the trade,
you're supposed to make money on when
you've,
when you've done it,
but now we've got,
you know,
derivatives and derivatives of
derivatives,
of derivatives on there,
which is just a way of kind of shrinking
the.
Explain that for people don't know what
that means.
So if you buy a stock,
I mean,
you know,
you buy stock and hope it goes up and
then you sell it in the future.
If you'd rather make up that time right
now,
I can sell it in the future right now,
right?
I can basically sell that future sale
because I think that sales is going to
be a good one now.
Right?
I can say,
what if I did that trait?
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna have it now,
but
one of I trading,
then I'm trading.
I'm trading on,
on an abstraction from what something's
going to be worse at some moment in the
future.
So it's like I'm trading on the stock
over time and then someone else will
say,
well,
I'm going to trade on the abstraction of
that.
I'm going to trade on whether or not
people think the stock in the future is
going to be worth more next minute.
Then this minute it's like,
well,
what's that?
So basically what you're doing is you're
buying stock over time,
over time,
over time.
Over time,
you're creating these things,
these derivatives of whatever the
original investment was,
which is kind of just a derivative of
the thing,
right?
There's the pork belly,
this derivative,
the pork belly derivatives,
and the derivatives.
Derivatives of derivatives,
of the derivatives,
all,
all ever tighter ways of saying what is
pork belly going to be worth,
you know,
on February third,
why is that legal?
Well,
it's legal because what it.
Because the economy requires it,
right?
We have a kind of money,
That has a clock in it.
It's lent into existence and has to be
paid back more than got lent out.
So our economy needs to expand by hook
or by Crook.
Somehow it has to grow in order for it
to survive.
That's just the way central currency
works.
They need to find more surface area for
the money.
More ways for people to buy stuff.
So instead of just having,
there's not enough of a company to buy,
so now we can bet on how that company's
going to do in some future date.
We can bid on that or we can bet on
that.
Right.
But what we're really doing is trying to
kind of compress all of this time,
right onto like the head of a pin so we
can bet on that.
So I don't have to sit and wait,
you know,
3000 years for facebook to be worth
something I can trade on his future
worth now.
But the whole joke of that is people who
are trading that way,
there are these computers that are
trading faster than them.
So I put in one of my super fast,
crazy,
you know,
um,
derivative trade.
Goldman Sachs sees that order coming in
on the computer.
They're so close to the exchange,
they can execute an order before my
order even goes through based on having
seen that I was going to do what I'm
going to do.
So they can literally trade in my
future.
Right.
I am in their past though.
That's,
that's digital time shifts.
That sounds like it's cheating.
That's like someone running a quick
server and they're local and then you
have like 150 paying.
Exactly.
That's bullshit.
I think so.
It will be so bullshit.
The irony of it is it's gotten so big,
right?
Derivative trading is bigger than
regular trading,
so the New York Stock Exchange actually
just got bought.
The exchange itself got bought by its
derivative exchange,
so it's almost just like the proof's in
the pudding.
It's like the derivative owns the market
at this point,
but that's allowed that how.
How could the government even ever deny
how incompetent they are when they
allowed that,
like that alone to like someone should
just have a broadcast on national
television,
a one of those town hall sort of events
where you sit down with the main people
that run the country and go,
how the fuck are you allowing this?
How?
How will you,
if not,
fix this.
Why would you ever try to do anything
else before you fix this?
When they made the decision,
they genuinely thought it would be good
for business in the short term.
I will never understand.
Big business people promise them,
figure it out before it got really bad.
Oh my God,
we'll figure it out before it got really
bad.
How much bigger is the derivative
economy?
I don't know exactly.
I mean it seemed.
I was looking,
trying to find out what the,
what the sort of trading was.
It seemed,
from what I could tell,
like 94 percent of trades are now
derivative because they're in because
they're.
Because there's such a bigger volume,
so that's insane.
No one's gonna like,
you're not going to buy 10,000
shares of Honeywell today because
that's,
you know,
whatever.
$60,000
or something.
But you could buy like 10,000
futures on Honeywell because they're,
oh really?
Gee God,
that is so crazy.
Percent of the trades are.
And how many more?
It's,
I think it's ultra fast.
Two is a whole other.
There's sort of two different.
Two different realms.
But yeah,
to huge.
They must all be crazy.
Everyone involved in the must know that
they're bringing on the matrix.
They must know that they're there.
They're the first steps before the
digital machine takes over.
They must know.
They must know that there's no humanity
in that stock market.
Shit.
That's chaos and,
and again,
I don't want digital technology to get
blamed for this,
right?
Because the real operating system
they're promoting is not the digital
operating system.
It's the economic operating system
underneath it.
It's this 13th century central currency
interest bearing,
debt based economy,
and none of the guys who I thought we'd
get us out,
you know Evan Williams with twitter,
Mark Zuckerberg,
with facebook,
the kids from Google,
right?
They're getting the.
Each of them had a real shot.
Even Bill Gates at breaking the central
economy and and flipping things the
other way.
Not going,
not going public,
not be good,
not doing it with venture capital.
Saying if I can,
if,
if Google can hack web search,
if facebook can hack social,
if twitter can hack everybody,
why can't they?
If they're so busy disintermediating all
these different things,
why doesn't anyone of them yet want to
disintermediate central banking and say,
no,
Mr.
Chase,
we don't actually need you.
We're gonna do our whole thing through
kickstarter.
Say like one of your didn't want to hear
things.
Yeah.
That's an interesting point of view.
I think they probably would never want
to take that stand because they would be
killed.
I would imagine there's a lot of money
in,
uh,
in them not being successful with that
quest,
you know,
to the point at which,
you're doing paper,
okay,
we're gonna let people do individual
transactions.
That was their original model and they
were going to make money on the float
and then the banks came to them and
said,
ah,
you're not allowed to do that.
You're not a bank paypal kids.
You've got to be,
you know,
can I just start as a bank or you're
going to have to be connected to one of
us and that's when,
you know,
pay pal kind of becomes part of Ebay
rather than whatever these crazy guys
might've done.
And I suppose there's this point where,
you know,
innocently these companies that get
bigger and bigger and bigger,
hoping to do the right things,
and then it's like,
we're gonna,
we're not gonna let you do this if you
don't,
if you don't play by our rules.
But uh,
I also feel like there's companies that
if you,
if you're willing to go smaller,
if you're willing to let it grow a
little bit slower,
that you can scale up,
you can become a big ethical
corporation.
Yeah.
I was always wondering why a big
corporation couldn't be ethical.
Why?
Why can't you have a big corporation
with a,
a good ideology behind it?
But I think it's really because of
shareholders and shareholders are
inpatient.
Shareholders are there.
They're not really there,
right?
They're distant.
They're shareholders are,
are people who just want to see a number
go up by the next quarter.
And if you have to make a number go up
by the next quarter,
then you're going to have to be thinking
about something other than doing good in
the world.
You if it is ones and Zeros at all
costs,
if that's the game you're playing and if
you've got shareholders,
then you're going to throw you in jail.
If you don't do that,
I mean that's your fiduciary
responsibility and it's a fascinating
thing that a corporation can do
something that an individual would be a
total piece of shit to do.
If it was one person that was involved
in this one guy,
what he did was he,
you know,
he gave the loans to the Third World
Company,
the countries that they couldn't pay
back.
He went over there,
monopolize our natural resources
himself,
dug the oil,
lie himself,
polluted the river himself,
you know,
raped and killed the villagers himself.
He'd be like,
Jesus Christ locked that fucking guy in
jail.
He's making people work for $5 a week.
You know that guy.
There he is there he is holding down,
you know,
but because it's a corporation,
you're like,
well,
they're making money for their.
Exactly.
And how many people who on the one hand,
you know,
we'll read a good magazine or something
or listen to us and,
and NPR and,
and be all sad about that stuff.
Still has a 401k plan with stocks in the
very companies that are doing those
things.
So they're the ones who actually own the
company.
They're the shareholder who wants to
think to go up so they could send their
kid to college.
You know,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's interesting how circular it gets.
So I mean,
for,
for how unvirtuous that circle is
though,
I think unwinding it is just,
is just as easy.
So it's like,
okay,
instead of doing these sort of long
distance,
longterm disconnected investments in
mining companies,
I'm going to invest my money where I see
it and people actually know in the place
where I am,
who are trying to do something,
you know,
and bring it,
bring it,
if not,
uh,
if not local,
at least at least into your present,
at least into your,
into your visible reality.
Yeah.
And it really is the,
the,
the pursuit of the end goal of simply
only ones and zeros done through a
corporate way is really anti human.
I mean that's the,
that's the real anti human aspect of it
is that it will engage human suffering
as long as it's willing to extract ones
and zeroes from that elected calculates
how much human suffering are we willing
to cause,
how much devastation to the environment
or are we willing to cross so much,
you know,
which is why.
Then the question becomes,
I mean in the nightmare scenario then is
you invest that into technology so that
your robots,
no,
they're not in competition with us,
but they are playing the corporate
program.
They have no desire other than to
extract,
extract value and meaning from it.
And those computers running algorithms
recognize trends in the marketplace
before a human could ever see it coming.
And then round countered.
And meanwhile,
as we're making ourselves dumber about
technology or I'm wearing this code
academy tee shirt,
right?
Want people to learn to code.
As we become more stupid about our
computers,
our computers are getting smarter about
us doing big data repositories of every.
Every keystroke,
right?
Every are there.
They know,
they know stuff about,
I think knew some teenage girl was
pregnant before family did and you know,
they know when kids are going to be gay
before they know themselves,
you know,
it's like things got really smart and I.
You go to a google when you google
something or look for things,
certain things online and then say you
go to youtube and there's ads for things
that you've recently looked at is scary.
Tantalizing ads.
Oh I see you're into jeeps.
Why we have a jeep for sale and it's a
new jeep and here's a video you can
click on and their ab testing that you
know,
understand which is which he reacted
last girl or not girl and cheap
correlation.
Okay.
Give him that next time.
Tits,
tits.
Like they'll show you everything that
you're into and you like you son of a
bitch.
How do you know about all this?
It's weird and it's just the beginning.
We're accepting it slowly accepting the
needle and to our vein pumps in nano
cells that eventually replace human
tissue.
If there's going to be a commercial is
going to be an artificial guys is going
to be saying why would you want to be
natural?
You're going to rot.
It's not fun.
Life gets even better as you get a buyer
buyer little nanobots to from like the
most reputable company,
you know,
the one that you really like and the
great user agreement.
And then,
but then after it's in you,
it's like they get bought by google and
all of a sudden your user agreement
shifted,
you know,
agree to,
do you want to have,
you know,
uh,
do you want to remember your children's
names?
Okay.
Then sign that's used this new user
agreement.
Otherwise you get no's.
No data.
You have enough for two people to phone
numbers.
Your emergency 911 phone,
like your phone.
It's not registered at only relate to
call nine.
One one.
That'll be the same thing.
Well,
you should've paid your bill,
Mr Rushkoff.
I don't know why he didn't want to pay
your bill and here you are with no
recourse.
Yeah,
you're going to look at a shiny guy from
the future of thousand years old and it
looks great,
but again,
it'd be all artificial.
Yeah,
but again,
it's not with all that artificial knees.
It's not necessarily,
although it may be it,
it's not necessarily the technology
that's the problem in this equation.
You're the company that owns the
technology,
right,
but ultimately what's getting done,
the technology's getting pushed.
That seems to be the case in every
single situation and ultimately at the
top of the execution food chain where
you look at like what is being done at
the end level.
That's really the game changer.
The technology constantly increases with
every overtake,
with every new gigantic invention and
bundles of money that go along with it
and all the people that got fucked over.
At the end of the day,
the technology keeps moving forward and
it keeps getting stronger and stronger
and stronger and it's.
But it's not just stronger that it's,
it's,
it's fundamentally different.
I mean,
that's the thing that Mcluhan was trying
to bring up in Marshall Mcluhan,
the media theorist.
He was looking at that,
the different environments that
different media,
different kinds of technology create.
So you know,
fire had a change.
They had a media environment,
had a technological environment with
fire.
Now you know,
people could go live further north in
colder places and little apes,
you know,
who were smart enough to have fire,
could get away from big dumb apes who
couldn't travel north to chase them.
You know,
we got different races and all sorts of
things happen because it's sounding like
fire or the invention of text or the
invention of text changed.
Well for me it changed the way we look
at time,
right?
Because now I can write something now
that I'm going to be accountable for
later.
So we can have contract with text.
We got history,
we got the Judeo Christian line of
thought.
We got law and ethics,
you know,
we got our,
we got the calendar,
you know,
then that all went along and we
developed.
Then we get the printing press and we
get the clock right now,
the clock,
all of a sudden we go,
oh wow.
Now we can actually break down the day
into these little pieces.
We put one up at the town square and
that's when time became money.
That's what it was like,
okay,
now you can work for an hour for me
instead of making a thing that you're
connected to and selling it to me,
now you can work for the hour or two
hours or three hours.
We got to standard and now we get the
digital media environment,
you know,
which is just as different as the
industrial age media environment.
That.
And the clock was from the printing
press,
from the written text,
from,
uh,
from even fire.
You know,
and in the digital media environment,
there's this,
uh,
it's not just more tech,
it's,
it's more,
it's more of a sense of,
of moving through time and a choice.
Two choice,
two choice two choice way.
You know,
where we just have more choices than we
know what to do if we spend more time
processing choice itself than we do.
Getting the things that we've chosen,
you know,
it's like the call waiting is almost
like the typical kind of digital choice.
It just ended our,
I'm talking to this level and I've got a
call waiting.
What do I do?
You know,
just to be put in that,
just to be put yourself in that,
in that interrupted state is very
digital because you want to have the
choice because that person wants to
reach you.
But how,
you know,
how that interrupts what,
uh,
what used to be a more continuous way
of,
of just moving through life.
Yeah.
It,
it certainly gives us more options and
we're naturally designed to handle.
And the more people have on their
facebook page,
the more likely they really have zero
connection to those people.
The,
the idea.
I mean like,
like we're,
we're designed for Dunbar's number,
right?
One hundred 50 people and you get,
get 5,000
people on your facebook page.
Well,
who the fuck does that mean?
Who are you talking about marketing and
you know,
what,
what kind of interaction that you really
happening,
you know,
it's not the same.
It's not a human to human interaction.
The other weird thing that facebook for
me,
again,
it's how it compresses time,
so it's like there are these people from
like second and third grade.
I'm finally,
you know,
45,
whatever years away from that and then
it's like two weeks ago from second
grade,
it's like,
God,
I'd finally,
I'd left that behind me.
It's unmarked.
Yeah.
I don't know who she is.
It's I was or who she relates to.
It's just,
it was in the past for a reason and now
it's here,
but then on the front end I've got the
computer on the other side,
calculating everything about my
keystrokes so they know my future.
They know who's going to be pregnant,
who's going to be gay,
who is going to be,
this can be that.
There was like,
okay.
So it was like my past is all in here
and now my future is all in here and
everything's just sort of crushed in on
me there.
I don't feel.
I don't feel autonomous anymore.
I don't feel like I have agency.
I don't feel I'm in charge.
I can't get away from anything and I
can't actually be moving towards
anything with a sense of free will,
but can you.
I mean you're,
you're sort of in control of how much to
interact with it,
how much you choose to use it.
That's why I dropped facebook.
You dropped it.
I was just like,
too much.
But you still use twitter?
Yeah.
What?
What's there?
Stays there.
Facebook problematic.
Facebook is a problem that will.
A real problem with facebook is I'm not
in charge of what I do on facebook.
Why is that?
Because Mark Zuckerberg can use me or my
likeness in an ad of something that I
don't even know what it is.
He can't do that anymore than I thought.
Oh really?
He undid that.
I think that was something that wasn't
supposed to happen.
Supposedly.
Are they backtracked about that?
They do.
They go two steps forward,
one step back just to forward one step
back.
It's sort of an ever evolving user
agreement.
I mean,
we're the part that I had gotten
concerned about what?
I'm on there as an author.
Right.
I'm on there,
buy my book.
Love me.
You know,
and like my ideas,
um,
I can't do that.
I can't solicit the likes of other
people have readers,
people who I'm supposedly a advising
about this stuff,
especially about sort of media ethics
and integrity.
I can't invite them to like my page when
that very active liking is making them
vulnerable to marketing,
that's going to be passing through me
beyond my control.
Yes and no because they're also
providing you with this excellent
connection with all these people that's
available through facebook,
which not as limited as twitter with 140
characters.
I'm willing to pay for the privilege to
reach those people,
but I'm not willing to have them and
their likenesses used to represent
things.
I don't think that they understand that.
What liking makes someone vulnerable to,
you know?
I don't think so.
I mean on some senses is patronizing.
I guess what I'm saying is I think I
know stuff about this technology that
they don't.
If they all knew really how this worked,
if they all knew the implications of
what they were doing,
then I would say,
let's,
let's go for it.
But ultimately the worst consequences is
what marketing they're going to be
marketed to going to be represented.
So their image would then be put on
something.
Oh,
so,
but no,
I'm pretty sure that I'm 100 percent
sure they didn't.
They dropped that thing of using their
photos and advertising.
And you're not going to profit.
They're not allowed to just take your
photos and just,
uh,
just photos.
No,
they're not going to do it.
With your photos that you're talking
about is,
are you talking about the photo,
the photo thing they bought?
I'm talking about using,
but for,
you were saying like using it for
advertising sponsored stories and how
they use people in a sponsored story.
At least the day that I quit at that
point it would not.
Oh,
you can turn that off.
But yeah,
that,
that there's things like that that are
on,
but there's ways
turn them off.
I'm confused.
There are sponsored story,
but do you mean people don't know?
I feel like most people don't know and
just to be there,
it just didn't seem like it also because
I so don't trust who they are.
And what they're,
what they're about.
I don't trust them as a company the way
I want to trust the kinds of companies I
let get bigger and bigger and deeper and
deeper into my lives and eventually put
probes in my brain and do not trust them
because Justin timberlake played him in
a movie.
The other one,
he played a Shauna to put the good guy.
No,
he played the mindspace story and how
much of it is about coke and horse for
her,
because I would have with those guys and
they just take that money crazy.
If you're going to take facebook,
if you're going to say you,
I don't trust facebook.
You can't trust twitter.
You can't trust google.
You can't trust any of the snow.
I'm aware right now I'm aware of the
ways that twitter is broadcast.
I feel in control of how I'm tweeted and
retweeted.
Almost
worse though,
because they're actually to the point
where you try to go back in time and
your timeline.
You can see there gets a cutoff point
where you can't download your own tweets
unless you know the exact link.
Then they end up giving you your
history.
They said,
I still can't do it on mine,
and that's the same with like twit picks
are all these photo ones,
like some of them.
Now you're saying that some inches.
Okay.
You're saying that you want your.
If you're going to do tweets you want or
should have been an addition for your
free,
for your free tweeting.
You want them to maintain an archive of
you and everyone else.
Well,
I'm,
I,
I personally,
I personally don't have a problem with
it,
but when I'm saying
is that that's kind of more ridiculous
to me than facebook.
The fact that I can't even access stuff
that I've,
that I've totally different thing I'm
concerned about.
I mean this is what in the book I call
it digit Phrenia,
you know,
I feel like the problem with,
with digital for most people,
it's not this idea of information
overload,
that there's too much stuff coming at
them,
but they're,
they can't maintain more than one online
persona a simultaneously.
There's too many sort of individual
instances of us and if you're going to
have different instances of yourself,
you know even your email inbox is an
instance of a sort.
If you're gonna have all these different
different things out there filling up or
interacting,
you want to be damn well sure that
you're in charge of each one of them and
I didn't feel.
I felt like facebook was now doing
things on my behalf.
I was like one step of control.
When you make a very good point in that
having more than one version of yourself
becomes very problematic.
Especially if you're involved in any
like real.
I mean I'm sure you probably interact
with quite a few people every day and to
do that on twitter's semi manageable.
Do it to do it when you can,
but to do that on twitter and then they
have to hop over to facebook too.
It's like you should have one portal in
one portal.
At least one.
That's one that I was always sad,
you know,
because I don't really.
I didn't go to facebook much.
I go there and they'd be like some
relative,
you know,
who said,
oh,
I just heard of your mom's passing.
It was like six months have gone by
before I found that message.
You don't want to console them or
whatever.
Um,
it's,
it's just such a,
it's for me,
it was such an awful interface anyway
that I was just losing,
losing stuff there.
But yeah,
it's uh,
I don't think it's just has to do with
how I get more,
uh,
correspondence from other people.
So I've got a,
I've got to limit it more than others.
I think it really has to do with,
um,
well if anything,
it's at least I'm the canary in the cage
for what's coming for everybody else.
I mean,
you know,
people will need to get one or two
emails and now it's just streaming in
for everybody.
Yeah.
If you send me something on Facebook,
I don't read it just to let everybody
know because they pile up.
I don't have time to read them.
So I'm with you in a certain way.
I still use facebook to put up links,
but it's connected to my twitter and I'm
pretty cognizant of that.
So when I put a tweet up on,
when I put a link up on facebook,
I make sure it's short enough to fit
into a tweet with,
with,
with twitter.
I mean you,
you understand what you're putting out,
you put out this little hundred 40
things,
it went to your people and those words
are out there.
It's like a tool like facebook.
You don't really have the same sense of
ownership over what's going and you
don't have,
you don't actually have it.
Right.
Your picture is used.
Douglas went into starbucks just now.
Yeah.
I could turn it off so everyone should
turn it off.
So again,
you know,
it's like,
I feel like it's a useful,
it's a useful tool,
but it's,
it's a part of the untrustworthiness of
a good portion of the net.
Yeah.
Well,
I could see that with someone else being
in control of the,
uh,
the,
the interaction and someone else being
controlled ultimately of like when you
sign a user agreement and you have all
this information,
they just sort of put up online.
You're,
you're entrusting it to them and then
turn their marketing to you.
I mean,
that's a really good clean relationship
as long as they don't fuck you.
But yeah,
I mean,
and there's a point at which,
you know,
I'm all,
I'll let Netflix and it,
whoever's in behind my TV remote.
I mean now they know all that stuff,
right?
I mean,
I'll let them craft commercials around
me.
It's like,
oh,
I'll accept in this,
in this little,
uh,
arrangement we have with business.
I'll accept anything incoming,
you know,
but don't use me for your outgoing know.
Otherwise,
once you're taking the person's identity
and then saying,
Oh,
you know,
alice down the street like this,
a Sitcom to,
you should watch that.
And then my,
what I'm watching is getting broadcast
to them or what they think I'd be
watching.
That's where it starts to be like,
oh,
now I'm being disembodied,
now I'm being taken.
I think it's facebook is one of the most
popular websites online and it's also
one of the best ways to waste time,
like you can waste a day easily just
looking at people that you used to have
sex with you and I'll just fire them and
go,
what is this picture up to?
Oh my goodness,
look,
you know you could do that all day.
You go through that all day.
That could be entertained and you're not
getting shit done.
It's the same.
It's like I try to use twitter.
I'm one of the things that I do with it
is when we're.
Whenever someone sends me something
fascinating and a link,
I retweet it and because of that you
become like a portal for cool shit and
people know that if they send me cool
shit,
I'll retweet it and so you get all this
cool shit just starts coming to you.
When you sort of have that idea and then
you send it,
they send it to you and then it becomes
this really exponentially expanding
thing where you know,
you,
you have this like a radio channel or,
or like an information dump.
What percent of the tweets that you get
do you think you would pass on?
Um,
it's not that high percentage because
it's not always filter.
Well,
I'll have to look at it,
you know,
I mean if it's really interesting I'll
look at it,
but sometimes they'll send you something
and like,
oh dude,
that's nonsense.
Like,
what are you talking?
Did you see where this came from?
Like you read the link,
know that is not big foot and that guy's
refrigerator.
Shut the fuck up and stop telling me
this.
But what that makes you a reliable.
A reliable filter.
Yeah.
You can't just retweet things,
but I do read occasionally if someone
sends something really preposterous,
will retweet it.
Just to see how people react.
You know,
there's um,
or if someone,
if people get mad at me,
I'll retweet it just to see how they
react.
It just,
it's just we live in strange times.
It's uh,
the,
the twitter interface is a very bizarre
one.
The idea that you only give them 140
characters and people abuse the shit out
of that.
Sometimes people will send me like 30
tweets in a row,
like explaining something to me,
like to stop the,
of things like snapchat.
You played with that or no,
what is that?
The one where you take a picture and it
like,
you can send it but it dissolves in like
three seconds or five seconds.
So it's like kids apparently.
I mean this is the dark secret.
Kids are leaving facebook,
you know,
the,
the demographic,
the younger like thing or in the 16 it's
like falling totally off and they're
doing things like snapchat because they
don't want,
they don't want to be putting everything
they're doing on their permanent record.
I mean they're finally kind of accepted
that they can show someone they're
posting.
It only lasts for three minutes.
You screenshot it though and then you
save it,
upload it.
Well he knows,
but if you screenshot it,
it at least tells them that they've,
uh,
I mean,
so it's been defeated,
but if you screen save it,
they at least the person who sent you
the thing knows that you did,
that they've given,
given their control.
But yeah,
but just this quest for truly uh,
Julie present based non archivable
silliness,
but it's because when we were silly we
got to do in the parking lot of the
seven slash 11.
It's like,
and there was no camera in the back
either.
It was really just it.
What happens in the standard seven,
11,
seven,
you know,
now it's like every single silly thing
they did,
if they didn't post about it,
their friend posted about it.
So it was still up there.
And it's like,
may as well.
We pitched passion to the side of the
Parthenon.
Not only that,
but the ideas behind what you can and
can't do or enforced by these archaic
laws that were written when none of this
digital technology was available.
So because of that,
he get a lot of weird shit happens.
Like there's one girl who got charged
with child pornography because shape,
she was sending photos of her naked body
to boys in her class and so the cops
arrested her and charged this young
girl.
She was 15 years old with child
pornography sending pictures.
Yeah.
I mean you talk about losing the
scripts.
That's,
that's really losing the script for
life.
I mean that was,
that is the nuttiest shit ever.
You're,
you,
you found a child porn king pin,
right.
There happens to be a child.
It was like,
yeah,
exactly.
Zero tolerance son.
It doesn't matter if she's a child,
but her vagina doesn't matter son.
She's a criminal.
She's victimizing probation is rape.
Exactly younger.
She's feeding the dark hunger,
so we need to discourage this in a big
way.
Solitary confinement.
But that's really just a temporal lag
hopefully.
Yeah.
So I think in our last then catch up,
are we.
I mean,
and also,
I mean in some sense a lack of privacy
could help that along too.
It's like if you know,
if Google cameras finding like tens of
thousands of people who are just smoking
joints in the streets of every American
city,
you know,
some point they have to go,
okay,
let people smoke pot,
let gays get married.
Say yes,
except the pod thing.
There's money in enforcing it.
The biggest issue,
more money in enforcing it or being in
selling it?
No,
but it would be two different people and
you have to pry it from the hands of the
people that are making money by keeping
it illegal.
Whether it's the private prison
industry,
whether it's the prison guards unions,
whether it's different pharmaceutical
companies that would stand to lose
profits,
whatever.
There's gonna be a bunch of people that
are trying to stop anything,
any change,
especially changes in legalities because
there's a big business in locking people
up for shit I know,
so they're going to have to maintain a,
an illegal population to stay alive.
They're going to have to rest more and
more if they're going to have corporate
growth.
Greater greater percentage of America
has to be in prison every single year
until it's an Asam Tata curb and there's
one guy left.
That becomes a really interesting
scenario.
If marijuana does become legal and you
can trade on the future of marijuana,
what the fuck man,
I want.
It does have it.
There are some stocks that are marijuana
stocks really at that people trade.
How is that possible?
Well,
they're the companies that I guess that
I've already laid out a marijuana
strategy or are they ready for it?
Look at that percentage of the US prison
population that are non violent drug
offenders in the 1980 and then in 2012
percent and in 2012,
it's 25 percent.
Yeah,
the war on drugs folks,
they're winning.
More people are in jail I guess is.
I mean they're winning and no,
as long as we have a private prison
system,
it's good for the economy,
the whole thing.
It's fucking bananas.
Just the.
The fact that in this day and age you
still can't make a logical argument as
to why certain things are legal and
illegal.
Certain things that are legal,
which are devastating to your health,
and then when you find out that
information has been withheld and that
companies may have new known about
certain risks,
no one seems to go to jail if anything
happens,
people get find a little bit.
But if that was an individual person
that did that,
oh my God,
there would be a horrible human being,
a personal person.
One person who's responsible for all the
deaths that came from aspirin alone.
You would want to add what's.
That's why there's some,
there's some ways to get more conscious
of it though,
because it's all of us,
right?
It's all of us who are part of that
system are owning that corporation,
has shareholders or whatever.
And there are these things like,
um,
have you ever seen that slavery
footprint Dot Org?
No,
it's a,
it's a fun website.
You got to do it when you're feeling
good about yourself though.
What it does is,
um,
uh,
you,
you put in everything that you own.
If you have a car,
not where you live and this and that,
and it calculates how many slaves are
working for you right now.
God and like with like whatever.
Getting that.
Yeah.
Getting the Molybdenum for your iphone
or whatever it is or you know,
losing their fingers in some molybdenum,
molybdenum,
Molybdenum to metal.
Is it a rare,
rare metal?
Wow.
I never that one.
I've just recently heard a cold Tan.
That's the stuff that they get in the
Congo than for self.
Something that's really good with
activity or something to do with the
electronic connectivity in the use of
cell phones.
So it's,
I've,
I've found that to be so bizarre and one
of the more bizarre things in life that
the most complex stuff that we use,
like cell phones,
computers,
that the very base of it,
the origins early,
there's a mine,
there's a hole in the ground.
Also human suffering,
which is why I don't like the idea that
my computer,
which could really do everything I
needed to do is rendered obsolete by
changes in operating systems that really
are unnecessary except to sell another
computer.
You know,
the difference does not,
uh,
but I don't think necessarily because
they're trying to continue to improve
the product and they're continuing to
add more functionality and believing
that or at least at the rate at which
they do.
I sometimes feel like there's a,
a,
it used to be sort of windows and Intel
that you know,
windows and make it complex operating
systems so that you'd have to get the
next intel chip and then Intel would,
we'd create a tweak on that.
That makes you the next,
uh,
next Windows operating system that they
sort of would leapfrog each other.
And it feels like that with them.
Yeah.
You know,
you're,
yeah,
you're iphone is better things now.
Then three iphone to go.
But what about all these iphones in the
garbage and all these people who lost
all this stuff and the amount of time
compressed into one of these,
one of these devices is really intense.
You know that,
that at least one of our,
our,
our goals when we're developing new
technologies and new technology pathway
should be,
well,
what's the one that's going to actually
require the sales of the lease up,
the fewest amount of computers.
I don't know how many people are going,
how could we sell?
How could we need to sell less computer
so that we're,
you know,
people don't have to throw out these old
ones.
Have you seen those photos of Cuba,
of the old cars?
Because Cuba doesn't get new cars.
They have cars from like the fifties and
sixties and they are gorgeous.
They're beautiful,
but they do drive like shit.
That's the problem.
If you drive like a modern day BMW and
then you go back to willow,
stupid Chevy's from the 19 fifties,
those things are dog shit.
They break terrible.
They,
they handle like a horse on roller
skates.
Their ridiculous cars.
They're so stupid.
We know how to be thrown into rebel
without a cause today.
And you hopped in that car.
It will not be that.
It wouldn't be.
The experience were thinking.
They're talking shit.
They're terrible.
You could with a prius,
you could easily get away from some guy
in a 55 chevy.
There's no way you keep up.
Those things are terrible.
They can't take corners.
The breaks of his stupid drum brakes.
I mean they might as well have a rock
that you throw out that's attached to a
rope to slow your car.
Tell you,
take a.
You take a 57 t bird over a segue.
Yes,
yes.
Over just because it could rain.
Okay.
I liked the idea that,
you know,
they've managed to recycle these cars
and keep them working and keep them
running and it's really cool to see it
aesthetically.
It's beautiful.
It's gorgeous.
I mean you see a,
a modern street in this day and age and
you see these beautiful like,
and you can tell they're proud people
because these are shiny cars.
They're painted nice and they're done
well and they're restored well or,
or at least maintained well.
I mean,
I don't know how many miles some of
these cars have on them,
but they do look,
it does look amazing.
I know there is that,
you know,
I feel like there's a hunger for stuff,
not just fifties,
but also started to sixties madmen
period that this Dahlia for that,
so that,
that's right before this digital age
started.
That's like the height of the TV agents,
you know,
putting satellites in space.
There was that innocence,
you know,
it's funny because people look at these
kinds of shows and say,
Oh,
you know,
aren't they a Tibet,
Tibet there,
uh,
you know,
decadence.
And I was like,
no,
it's about their innocence,
you know,
they believe in,
they got,
you know,
it's that,
and you go around La,
it's like everybody's got hayward
Wakefield in their house and trying to
get those old g frigerators with this
sort of rounded coverage.
You know,
there's that longing for a,
like the industrial age just feels so
real.
You know,
it's a solid when people made stuff,
you know,
it wasn't just kind of printed,
right?
Yeah.
There's that,
that also like when you see those cars,
there's such a human element in that old
stuff.
Like even like sixties muscle cars,
like those were sort of like human
created works of art as opposed to,
you know,
you look at like a new Mazda or
something like that,
a real modern car and they're like,
it looks like something that just came
out of a machine.
They screwed it together and came out of
a machine.
You looked at like a 69 chevy that
doesn't like a Chevy Camaro.
Sixty nine Camaro.
That's something somebody fucking
screwed together.
There's some men work in behind that.
There's some people put tires on the
wheel and bolted in place.
There's some guys who work some
wrenches.
There's no doubt about it.
You look at that thing that's a
mechanical creation.
It's not a a computer creation and we're
slowly moving towards the Prius and I'm
fine with computer creation aesthetic if
it means that we don't have to work,
they didn't.
So they get rid of all those guys,
screw it in the screws and then let them
stay in their houses.
Fuck ended up,
fuck.
Those guys have to pick up a lot of
work.
They have to evolve with the times.
That's the whole thing too.
It's like,
so now we have.
The big problem in America is
unemployment.
Obama talking about getting jobs,
jobs.
Jobs are people who wants a job.
I don't want a job.
You don't want to jump.
People don't want jobs.
People want this stuff that you get when
you have a job.
They want the money that you get for
having a job,
but they don't want the jobs.
Right?
So meanwhile though,
we've got more than enough stuff.
We're burning food every week,
so you keep market prices high.
We're tearing down.
Bank of America is tearing down houses
in California because they're in
foreclosure.
You can't just let someone live in it.
It's going to bring price down.
They tear them down.
Why did they tear them down?
Because they're there.
Would have to sell at distressed prices
that would then lower prices of other
properties that they're trying to keep
up.
What it would cost them more money.
If you own 10 houses in a town and one
isn't going to sell,
you'd rather a tear it down.
Then if the bank comes along and create
some sort of a program to give houses to
needy people,
then it's going to lower the real estate
values of the,
of the mortgages that they've invested
in that are already teetering.
So they can't do that.
So charity itself becomes unprofitable.
It's never been quite profitable,
but that's like less than unpalatable.
What if we figured out that okay,
we only need rather than having
everybody work 40 hour weeks,
which is based on a clock and the
industrial age,
how much can we have people working at
weekend?
What if people don't really have to work
that much for us to have everything we
want?
But what if 10 percent of people could
work,
you know,
two days a week and we get everything
right?
So you go in,
you do your work.
I'm going to do my work in April 2007,
you know,
and then I'm going to go again in March.
What if it got that?
You really didn't need everybody working
all the time for everybody to have
stuff.
We couldn't deal with that.
Not because we don't have technologies
to do that.
We can't deal with it because we don't
have an economy.
We don't know how to divvy up the
spoils.
You know the reason that you have a job
is so that you can be entitled to a
share of what's actually in them in
abundance,
but because there's not enough jobs for
people,
we've got to rip up stuff and ruin stuff
that's in abundance because we can't
give it out.
There's also the social issue of not
having jobs when people don't feel like
they've made their own way or pulled
their own weight.
They feel unworthy,
they feel,
but you gotta replace employment with
work.
You know,
employment is a new invention.
Employment,
again,
industrial age.
We used to work for each other and
ourselves.
We only got jobs when we got the clock.
When we could work on the clock,
then we're employed or but we don't have
to be employed in order to work.
In order to have meaning.
If you don't have to have your job,
you don't stop,
so you just have to find a new niche
into the system.
You have to find a new thing that you
contribute to your to the world.
Yeah,
I completely agree with that,
but too many people find sort of a
preexisting way to interact and they
don't create their own way to interact
and in doing so,
you oftentimes miss on one of the best
things which is accomplishing things,
whether it's accomplishing starting your
own restaurant and keeping it open and
in or having a car shop that only fixes
a certain type of automobile that you
really love to work on.
You know when you can figure out a way
to do something that you actually have a
passion for that.
It's like the the,
the old cliche.
It stops becoming work.
It just,
it becomes you're you.
You don't really have a job.
You have a thing that you love and
you're in flow at that point and how
many people have that and that's problem
is you can't have it in this kind of
economy.
You can have it.
When you have this kind of education
system,
you can have it.
What about just real naturally dull
people that need to be pushed in certain
directions,
but you know,
so not everyone has to be the one that
figures out how to do the new method of
biodynamic.
Rudolph Steiner farming on their organic
community supported agriculture plant.
Someone can just go there and plant
plant carrots.
It's also the issue of how human beings
are raised in the first place,
which is so huge and not really
addressed the.
The reason why some of these people fall
into these mindless jobs is because
never along the line of they've been
stimulated neverland,
one by their family,
by the school systems,
by their environment,
by their atmosphere,
by their,
you know,
their fellow knuckleheads in their
community.
They're all just surrounded by people
who are either likeminded or less or you
know,
or support it and you kind of fucked.
And then when something comes along that
eliminates that job for that guy,
that robot job when he was 45 years old
or 50 years old and he has to start
again and sort of reignite some sort of
passion and curiosity or die off like a
dinosaur.
And it's hard too,
because he was liking the thing he did,
you know,
if he's a toll collector,
and you get better and better at it and
then you start,
you know,
then test to see how many people you can
make eye contact with when you're
getting the towels and the how many
lives can you change with that?
I mean,
Gosh,
he can be that you could live the
bodhisattva life as a toll collector.
You know,
they take that away from him and it's
not just that he can't be retrained,
he doesn't have motivation,
you know what I mean?
It's not his fault that they broke his
heart.
They should have a show where a guy's a
toll collector and just see how he
interacts with people and then give them
projects.
Like,
today you're just going to casually
mention your penis and let's see how
many people freak out back there.
Back to your reality roots.
Yeah,
that'd be funny.
You do.
You have to do a toll collector.
You got to do it pretty fast.
Well yeah,
that'd be a weird way to experiment how
people interact when they don't have to.
It was really quick.
You know,
how many people treat you like shit?
How many people were like,
how are you doing?
What's going on?
Everything.
Cool.
All right man.
Take care of.
You know this.
You're going to get a broad variety of
the way people interacted with you.
I think that'll be kind of fun.
Wouldn't like hold up as a series,
but maybe a one hour special.
The tall guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just have a guy and you have,
we have to do like break it up with like
a sit down.
Yeah,
the chairs and then have a discussion
about the last couple of ones that we've
seen and what it really means.
People love that fast track thing now
though,
they won't,
don't want to pay it.
Totally want to put that little thing up
there and they just go through like New
York is one of the weirdest scenarios
ever because somewhere along the line
they just decided to make people pay to
get to the city.
It used to be that they were paying to
get the bridge built,
but they paid that fucking thing off a
long time ago.
Every bridge got paid off a long time
ago,
but revenue is so intoxicating.
They just kept with it.
We can understand that in California
because we don't really have a plate.
We could get anywhere it was bitches
were built,
but now they got to all be rebuilt,
rebuilt.
I understand.
Hudson bridge.
They were building and building and
building and by the time they've
finished they had to start rebuilding it
again.
It was that many years.
Two reasons why that's nonsense.
The big one is,
is the dumbest way to make traffic.
You have a spot where everyone has to
stop on the way into the city.
That is so stupid.
When you are going from Long Island to
Manhattan,
that is the most maddening shit to do at
8:30
in the morning,
you want to fucking kill somebody
because it's so stupid box.
You should make people pay.
You know,
either either you could justify the
construction of the bridge,
the maintaining of the bridge,
but they should pay for through their
taxes and that's it.
There shouldn't be a spot we have to
stop because that's fucking dumb.
The only reason why you would want to do
that is you want to check cars for bombs
are nutty people or are you just trying
to discourage?
Yeah.
Well I guess maybe try to discourage,
get people onto the lirr and do rapid
transit the way God intended and
discourage people from coming into the
city because the easier it is to get
into the city,
the more the traffic sucks and it sucks
already.
It's terrible when make it suck and then
charge for making it knapsack stuck.
You can't fix the suck that way you just
suck $20.
We'll give you the green light.
Do you live in Manhattan now?
Do you live in New York?
I live in New York.
I live in Westchester County.
I lived in new Rochelle for a little bit
on Hudson.
Oh yeah.
It's um,
that's a,
that's a beautiful area.
That's nice.
The whole Westchester.
It's got some nice pots.
Yeah,
it does.
It's a little snooty.
Some of it.
So there's a couple of towns in
Westchester that kind of retained some
little shit to reality,
you know,
it's not just westchester is a weird.
It is though.
You'll be in a neighborhood where you're
seeing these mansions with these giant
lawns and then you'll go a half a mile
and you're in the projects and projects,
so it's a little more.
Jersey Jersey ask drive through the
oranges.
It's that.
It really,
you get that sense.
I mean,
most of Westchester is pretty a pretty
affluent at this point,
you know,
but you know,
it's not as affluent as Manhattan.
Manhattan is the most affluent and.
Right,
right.
Well,
yeah,
I mean you,
if you're inside Bloomberg's bubble,
if you made it in there somehow,
you know when you entered the apartment
was Amelia and I,
you've got $10,000,000
of real estate or something,
but um,
you know,
anywhere else doesn't quite.
It's not quite that.
Those places are madness.
Those multimillion dollar apartments,
like the way of living in the big city
like that is so alien.
It's only exists in Manhattan where you
have so many people living in apartments
and it creates a different community and
in,
in the sense it's more than than Los
Angeles.
Oh,
it is.
I mean,
most things about it are,
are kind of more consonant with our era
in our digital economy and all that.
It's a better carbon footprint is stack
people up like that,
that they have everybody.
I'm in lawns and fertilizer and whatever
else they get in the suburbs.
So,
I mean,
it's,
it's good on,
on most of those levels.
It's just New York itself is so crazy
expensive,
you know,
through God knows what sort of real
estate shenanigans are done.
That's what sort of then for me colors
the,
uh,
the experience of urban joy there,
you know,
there's no one is an artist or a writer.
Regular of a regular means could live
there.
Yeah.
That's where it gets really crazy when
you see a small apartment is like 3000
bucks a month and you're like,
okay,
that's just nuts.
That means a guy who makes $50,000
a year,
it has to give up three quarters of his
income to pay his fucking rent.
That's not,
that's right.
So it's like,
I mean,
I don't know if you need crime,
uh,
to make it better,
but you know,
you'd go back to the era of,
you know,
Basquiat,
he couldn't live in Manhattan and you
know,
none of that.
None of the folks from then one of the
ramones or.
Well they were queens actually,
but uh,
you know,
or Warhol or any of his 42nd street.
The real.
But that's the thing though,
it's like exhausting.
It was criminal.
It was,
you know,
it was awful.
Terrifying.
Yeah.
It was terrifying.
And yeah,
there's certain,
some part that wax nostalgic,
but that's not a good old days that you
really want to return to either.
It's just like,
how can you have a New York that works
and is still artistic and alive and
vibrant and fertile and not have people,
you know,
getting stabbed in the stomach.
Yeah.
And how can you have so many rich people
live in together?
Because you have to be rich to live
there.
I mean,
it's,
it's really difficult to pull off living
in Manhattan if you don't have at least,
you know,
upper middle class income.
So yeah,
it's a strange,
strange place.
Unlike any place in this country,
you know,
there's no place in the country that's
so overvalued and you can get a decent
apartment in San Francisco for half of
what you'd spend on an apartment in
Manhattan.
San Francisco now has gotten worse.
Something one of those lists.
Well,
look the worst.
There's some places outside of San
Francisco that are just insane.
Like we're,
I'm near Stanford.
Uh,
they have,
um,
I think it's called Atherton.
So the highest real estate in the
country.
Uh,
and you,
you look at these people that I know
have this house up,
there is an acre and a half is worth
$15,000,000
to fucking look into this.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
It doesn't make any sense,
but it's like everybody in that
neighborhood is all.
They're all tech people.
They all,
they all made insane amounts of money
and the various tech bubbles and booms
over the years and all that.
Google money's up there and all that.
Apple money's up there and there's just
a lot of fucking people that have
incredible amounts of cash up there.
So real estate,
they need houses.
This is what they live.
So real estate's through the fucking
roof,
right?
Like you will look if you look at,
like I,
I enjoy doing that sometimes.
Like could I live in Phoenix?
Let's see what,
you know,
what the neighborhoods are like in
Phoenix and I'll go look at real estate
in Phoenix for a goof.
You look in Atherton and what's
$11,000,000?
She'll like,
get the fuck out of here.
That's $11,000,000.
Well they got to be bike distance from
facebook or wherever.
It's an amazing bubble of,
of money.
And this strange one of really strange
one because again,
you go a mile over and we've stopped at
this Wendy's and it was like a really
sketchy Wendy's.
Like really?
Like this place is kind of fucking dirt
baggish to be a mile away from a $15
million dollar house.
Like it's so strange how there is no
middle anymore.
Yeah.
That sort of got,
got,
got spun out in the,
in the spin cycle at the end of the day.
This industrial age here.
Well you can't say there's none,
but I mean just and certainly a
diminished very little,
very little.
But you know,
like you're saying no,
if,
if that,
if that lower 98 percent or 99 percent,
whatever it is,
a gets fed up enough,
it'll network with itself rather than
trying to get something down from the
top.
I don't even fed up.
It seems like we only act when we forced
to act.
We need a desperation.
We need,
you know,
we need to have no options and then we
move into this new stage of
understanding what the fuck.
The real problem.
But that's.
And that's different.
And again,
that's,
that's the whole point of,
of being in the president of
presenteeism is that instead of going on
some Long March on some other 20th
century movement or this eyes on the
prize and just the means justify the
means battle to the future thing,
we go,
screw all that.
We just want it now.
We're gonna just do it.
That's what it was.
So encouraging about the occupy
movement.
What are your demands?
What do you want from us?
We didn't want anything from you,
you know,
it was like we're not going to stay at
our demands.
Were going to actually do this thing,
you know?
And that's where,
again,
we'll do what thing though,
there the real issue,
right?
To try to occupy the world in which we
live.
I love,
I liked in the occupy movement to white
blood cells.
Like they recognize there's an issue and
they gather around it and you know,
it's like if calls attention to the
issue and you know,
they're,
but they,
they're gathering around a six spot.
I mean that they know there's something
wrong here.
And so everybody's like,
oh,
this is the spot,
it's all going down right there.
They try to educate,
they do teach ends and learn about stuff
a lot.
A lot of people know more about these
issues now than did before.
And they see it as a super longterm
project.
I mean,
this year they did an occupied debt and
the debt jubilee.
So what they're doing is buying pennies
on the dollar,
the debt of people like you've got,
you know,
health bills,
they can't pay and all that because it's
just owned by credit companies.
So they buy the debt and just believe
it.
Wow.
So it's kind of cool,
you know,
they take $10 in relief,
like a thousand bucks a debt and it's
well worth it.
That's interesting.
That's a great idea.
And I think that's a great community
idea that there's a lot of people out
there that I have a spare $5 or a spare
$10 you won't even think about.
But if you get of those people,
you can
enact some real change and really help
people.
Um,
what do you think is like what,
what is the best way besides podcasting,
besides books and besides having actual
conversations with people where you
explore these ideas,
what is,
what is the best way to get people to
understand that true happiness really
does come from a sense of community
where one of the interviews that I saw
with you,
you were talking about your youth and
you were talking about living in a place
where you all shared a large backyard
and it became sort of a community thing
where everybody would get together and
have like a barbecue and then queens and
we had,
it was like one barbecue pit at the end
of the block that was just on all
weekend.
That's when we were lower middle class.
My Dad got a better job.
We leave Queens,
we'd go to Larchmont in scarsdale.
These,
you know,
these Westchester towns.
He.
Yeah.
And it's like you don't barbecue with
the Joneses anymore,
you barbecue it against the Jones.
It's like every single family has got
its own,
like $300 a weber grill in the backyard
and no one would think,
you know,
it's like you can invite someone over I
suppose,
but it's not that barbecuing was this
solo family activity and I was thinking
about as far as the grill company's
concern,
that's better.
They'd rather everyone have a grill and
nobody grilled together because then
they get to sell more grills,
you know,
but what it's like,
I've,
I've looked in my,
uh,
not the neighborhood I'm in now,
but never.
I almost went to because like everybody
on the block had a snowblower and I'm
thinking that's really weird.
There's like 10 houses with 10
snowblowers.
How many snowbirds do you need per
driveway?
It's like that.
Every two houses share one for every
four houses shared one.
Want to get up in the morning and you
don't want to talk to Mr Johnson can use
the snowblower first because you got to
be at work at 7:30.
You don't want to talk to Mr Johnson.
Is the phase a Douche bag?
Maybe.
Maybe you should be able to have your
own snowblower.
There isn't a huge bag is because he's
working overtime to save up for that
guy.
Yeah.
Well there's not a lot of people that
are happy out there as the roads quote
that most men live lives of silent
desperation today.
Loud desperation and Marshall McLuhan's
quote that humans are the sex organs of
the machine world and that has this
desire to keep up with the Joneses.
You got to pay for those Weber grills,
you know,
as the disconnects us,
I walk in a room now and I feel it feels
different when I see people sitting on
their devices.
You know,
you used to walk into a room with a
bunch of guys.
You walk in here and you guys have
devices,
but you can feel the family,
you know,
you can feel you guys are on an animal
level in touch with each other's vibe.
Right?
On whatever that subtle level is.
And I go into rooms now and I don't feel
the same group dynamic group presence
than I used to even teach in a class,
you know,
20 years ago versus going into one today
when everybody's reading what's going on
in there.
It's just different.
I'm not saying it's worse,
so though
I think it's worse.
I'm a qualitatively different
experience.
They have more choice over what they do.
They can divide their attention the way
they want,
they have more autonomy over all these
things,
but they're losing.
And maybe it's out there on the net
somewhere.
Maybe by the time we're in the great,
great second life we reconnect,
but they're,
they're missing a certain subtle animal
contact that we don't yet fully
understand.
Maybe he just needs to be mitigated.
Or maybe we need to just understand and
explore like the ethics of a when to and
not to use cell phones when to and not
to connect and encourage more connection
and like let people know.
They're like,
look,
that is an impulse.
Just like washing your hands too a or
just like there's like a lack of
satisfaction in the satisfying or the
completion of that impulse to check
twitter.
You check your twitter checking twitter
again,
what are you getting out of that?
Why not pay attention to the person
who's in front of you but you're doing
it so like a nutty person washes their
hands 100 times.
That's the whole point.
That's the whole reason I write in my
books are that book before this one is
called program or be programmed and the
idea was just to give people sort of the
10 biases of digital media.
Like they're really good for doing
things far away.
They're not going to be doing things
with someone in the same room because
they're.
They're just really simple stuff like
that or this time idea,
which is that digital technologies
asynchronous,
it doesn't live in time,
so don't you try to keep up with it
because it's not in your temporal
universe.
It's in its own,
you know,
and you can make it conformed to yours,
but certainly don't run and chase it.
It's that.
It's kind of,
it's at this point,
it's education,
it's just having the conversation
letting people.
That's the whole thing.
If they become more aware than you know,
then they stand a chance.
I certainly think a lot of these things
is sort of snuck up on us and we could
all do with a lesson or at least an idea
of how to manage them more.
Right.
More humanly.
Exactly.
In the trick is for people not to see it
and this has been my whole thing not to
see the messenger of this as the one who
saying,
oh,
this stuff's so bad.
Oh,
well the children are turning more
violent.
You know,
that whole kind of pbs ish hand wringing
thing that so many writers are out
there.
It's like,
are you for technology or against it or
for it or against it.
You know,
and if you're not just going,
Yay,
go business.
They think you're against it.
And it's like,
no,
I'm for technology.
I'm just against the way were happened
to be using it right now.
I don't think there's any.
I don't think it's a coincidence that
people are.
I think fundamentally less happy now,
I think than they have been in a long
time.
If you look at the amount of people that
are on medication for happiness,
it's really what it is and if you're on
an antidepressant,
essentially you're on a medication for
happiness and whether or not that's
because of a chemical imbalance that you
suffer from or because of the fact that
your job sucks in your life sucks and
you,
you just,
you're just filled with suck every day
and you're responding to the well for
whatever it is.
If you look at those numbers,
one or two things is happening.
Probably both.
One,
we're getting fucked over by these
pharmaceutical companies and they get
unethical doctors to prescribe that shit
with impunity and there's that for sure,
but then there's also like,
people are not connected to this world.
They don't,
they don't feel whole.
They don't feel satisfied in great pain.
It's better to only be in moderate pain
or mild pain.
If you can take a pill.
I mean,
what's hard to do is to get people to
go,
oh,
well actually that pain is,
is kind of a good sign because it means
that we all need to kind of work here to
change,
to change the way the world is and,
and,
uh,
and take some action.
The pain is trying to get you to change.
The paint is trying to get you to avoid
the pain and you should use your logic
to say,
well,
what's causing this pain?
But there's a disconnect.
I'm not,
I'm not emotionally satisfied.
I'm not connecting with my fellow
humans.
I'm missing something unless you're up
against the wall and there's nothing you
can do to change your circumstances and
wishing to take the pill.
That's the,
that's the danger there.
But I do think that more people can
start to get in touch.
You know,
for me it's these rhythms,
you know,
the rhythms of life,
the 28 day lunar cycle and the fact that
each week of a lunar cycle,
your neurotransmitters change,
right?
So you have siedel Coleen week followed
by a serotonin week,
filed by a dopamine.
We followed by a norepinephrine week.
It's like every month is one bump,
bump bump.
If you know that,
then you're like,
oh,
this is the dopamine week.
That's why I feel like this.
Or I'm getting strangely.
I mean,
we go to,
there's a website,
someone space.org
that he's got it,
he's got it laid out.
There was originally,
it was an Olympic trainer,
irving Dardick who figured this stuff
out.
He was,
uh,
doing exercising people at different
times of the day in different parts of
the month.
And they,
you know,
they've been looking at bio,
a biological clocks for many years ever
since the,
you know,
Major League baseball,
pretty much discovered jetlag that
people,
you know,
get more jet lag when they traveled west
to east and east to west.
And they realize all these clocks are
not folklore.
There's actually something going on
here.
So their circadian rhythms for the day
and the night.
But there's also all these other rhythms
controlled by different,
you know,
uh,
whether an astronomical features and
traveling like that really does fuck
with those rhythms.
Right?
Yeah.
Yup.
But as people get in touch with them,
um,
I think it could help us,
uh,
you know,
get out of some of these,
uh,
you know,
drug,
a drug relationships that we're having,
you know,
wherever you taking drugs in order to
compensate for those shifting
neurotransmitters because we're trying
to be on all the time.
I'm in sales so I got to be in sales
when I'm in dopamine week or in
Serotonin week,
you know,
and that's,
that's hard.
Well,
there's also the,
the arrogance of the human mind to think
that I can manipulate the human mind,
the human mind going like,
oh,
like how things are running here.
I think I am going to take over the
running of me and I'm going to invent
some shit that makes me run more to my
liking.
I'd rather just be okay with everything.
Uh,
I want to be high all the time and okay
with everything,
okay,
can you get that?
And then one day they're going to get
what you feel like when you're on
ecstasy and it's
going to be,
keep it all day,
just all day,
enjoying the world.
Wow.
You've never seen this guy,
this color blue,
you're going to be so happy to have
those though.
They don't like you genuinely have those
drugs because when,
if you're as high as you are an ecstasy
or as high as you are pot,
then you start figuring things out and
then you start unwinding that
relationship and becoming less dependent
on Sam.
It could even just a shift in the levels
of things and the approach to things
gives you a,
Oh,
this is a new consciousness space that
I'm occupying here for.
Whether it's a brief moment or a long
drawn out crazy trip and it's different
than the solar sort of palliative care
of.
Of Pharmaceutical.
Sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
That,
that does the exact opposite is true.
The ones that are available that you
could buy on a regular basis are the
ones that bring you closer to the hive.
Drone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Just to let you accept more and take
more.
Even Caffeine and alcohol,
you know,
such easier them to tolerate the one
that's interesting.
That's sort of playing both sides of
that,
of the field here is adderall.
You know what I mean?
Because they use it to control a little
kids,
adderall and Ritalin.
It's one of these add drugs that keeps
us kids from,
you know,
acting out or a different class.
But also the counterculture is taking it
for a,
you know,
to write,
to write or work or to get that,
uh,
kind of a right.
I've never fucked with it.
But the people that I know that I've
said it kind of hampers creativity.
Right.
I guess.
I guess it's more for a,
like a speed yet cramming for a test
drive.
Yeah.
Getting work done.
Organizing Shit.
Like my friend Robert Schimmel rest his
soul.
Uh,
he,
um,
he accidentally took it once and he had
heart issues.
It was kind of a crazy story.
He picked up the wrong pill,
someone else's prescription and took an
adderall.
Then he called his doctor.
It's like,
what am I in trouble?
I'm scared.
You know,
I got this heart condition and the guy's
like,
you're gonna be fine.
You're going to be fine.
You're just gonna you're gonna be,
you're going to be a doing a lot of
things over the next few hours and just
accept that so he takes any said he just
starts fucking organizing his office and
he sat down in front of his notes and he
said,
I got more work done than I've ever
gotten before.
But.
Well yeah,
that's why they call it speed,
but it's a,
it's a great.
Did pay a price.
The ultimate industrial age truck I
guess said it makes you more,
more productive,
more efficient.
Quite a few friends who've had an issue
with it.
Several,
you know,
uh,
a good friend,
very smart guy who just went,
I'm just got off of it and you know,
he,
he went crazy with it for like several
months and he was starting up a business
and working with a tech company and
there's was a lot of hours and he just
took a little adderall to help them
along the way.
And next thing you know,
he needed adderall.
Every man.
Yeah.
They do say this to sort of,
I think speed,
longterm speed use is the closest they
can model schizophrenia with drugs had
been on speed freak for a really long
time.
You get way closer than with any
psychedelic or something.
Yeah,
I taught both.
It just seems like it just red lines.
Your system.
Yeah.
Lindsay Lohan's
plead deal.
One string attached.
I want my adderall.
Was that TMZ?
Yeah,
she's supposed to be in that prison or
that Rehab for the next whatever 60 90
days is.
She's trying to get a plea deal so she
can be an adderall and wait a minute.
They're putting her in jail again.
Yeah.
What for this time?
Uh,
I think it was for hit and run back in
2010 or something like that.
I can't remember kid.
I've been following it.
Well,
there's another weird aspect of our new
society that children become famous.
You know,
back in the Shirley temple days when
they invented that.
Yeah.
Who would've ever thought that you would
get a person like a Lindsay Lohan?
We raised them from the time their child
and they never know anonymity and just
long to escape every day long you can
get fucked up and just drift away in a
drunken stupor and not have to think
about it.
Yup.
And they can't leave it as the thing
because they're also to,
to uh,
to add.
Yeah.
And if you do leave it,
it's almost worse to Vin a husband than
to be a never was.
It never was.
You see a person walking on the street,
you never go,
oh,
look at that loser.
He was never fast.
He just called.
There's a gosh,
I'll tell Ya.
It reminds me there was this moment that
I still don't know exactly how I feel
about it.
When they did the,
they did the brady bunch reunion.
It's like 10 years after the show,
whatever,
20 years.
And Jan didn't show up.
They had a different girl for Jan and I
was like,
coconut oil.
In other words,
she broke free and we'll move on.
She'd probably eat plums.
She probably got,
you know,
all this crap for not going.
And a lot of people probably thought,
oh,
because she's probably too screwed up or
some problem,
whatever.
And I'm like,
no,
you know,
you went,
you went into the future,
you know,
and we're not going to let that define
you no matter what.
Yeah.
Or she wanted money and they didn't.
Who knows,
who knows,
who knows?
Media is good for projecting.
There's something very sad about people
that live completely in the past.
Like if you were on a show in the 19
seventies and you're still going to
those autograph signing things and
tired.
I heard that it was Barbara Eden on the
radio,
you know,
Juma Genie.
Yeah.
And I was thinking,
man,
that's one of those.
It's one of those things.
Well Barbara Eden also was in a time
where you didn't make money like you
didn't get that residual cash or people
are still selling.
I dream of Jeannie.
She would still be getting a palace.
But no,
he didn't.
She didn't get a slice back in those
Gilligan's island days.
Those guys didn't make any money.
They got fucked over.
Gilligan's island days was uh,
the,
you know,
like back in the day,
they never knew about like syndication.
They didn't,
they didn't have any idea that things
are going to be worth so much money and
then in a digital form forever.
Dude,
I was supposed to be at my next thing by
now.
Whoops.
It's like five.
How long
is this?
Pug is a lot of b or do you just go,
just go down to the whole thing?
Yeah.
We never go for more than three hours.
Do you have to leave so that we're
supposed to go where you going next?
What is it?
What am I doing?
I mean,
I've already missed 13 minutes of it.
Um,
tennis or at least apologize Jason
Calacanis.
He does this conference called launch
and what does it,
and it's like Silicon Valley
entrepreneury what's going to happen
next and technology.
So is it like an interview or a podcast
and then have another podcast?
No,
a video podcast or listens to.
Um,
but that's like only like you click on
the thing for a digital theorists.
You in touch with numbers.
My front end.
And uh,
thank you.
And then Richard Mascara,
do you know him?
He does a dangerous dangerous minds
website or shouldn't really a great.
He used to do disinfection.
You invented that whole website.
Oh,
he did?
Okay.
Well Matt,
Matt stags through public.
He's on distant from.
Yeah,
that's how I know him from.
Alright.
So you gotta get the fuck out of here.
I do,
I do.
This has been an awesome conversation
and really fun and it's great to meet
you.
Great to meet you too.
Thank you very much for coming on.
And people please go pick up his book.
It's called a future shock present.
Excuse me.
Present shock when everything happens
now.
Right.
So it's available now.
Is it available on audible.com?
Um,
they just did that.
The company that just emailed and said
they want to do the uh,
do the audio,
the audio,
but better.
Goddammit.
It's crazy that it's not needs to be
done right.
Audible,
go,
go get it.
Go get on it.
Um,
but um,
uh,
you could get it right now on Amazon.com
or your website?
Douglas Rushkoff Dot [inaudible] dot
com.
Thank you very much man.
I appreciate it.
A lot of fun to meet you.
Thanks to the sponsors of the podcast.
Thanks to audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book and 30
free days of audible service.
Um,
thanks also to stamps.com.
And if you click on the link on
stamps.com
and use the code j r e u,
uh,
you get a special offer,
no risk trial plus a hundred and $10
bonus offer including a digital scale
that you should not use for illegal
purposes.
Thanks.
Also to hover hover.com
forward slash.
What is it?
Rogan or something.
I have to have too many fucking thing.
Shouldn't take it all the same.
Yeah I should but I don't have control
of that shit.
Hover.com
forward slash [inaudible] go there,
get 10 percent off your domain name
registrations and they give you a free
shit like who is domain name privacy and
they're awesome.
And thanks also to onnit.com.
Go to o,
n n I t,
and if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you save yourself 10 percent off any of
our awesome supplements.
All right folks,
that's it for the week.
Uh,
I got shit to do.
Yo.
I'm busy.
I got a lot of things happening and the
next week is going to be a little sketch
because I'm on the road for most of the
week,
so we might bang out one only next week.
Try to get through it.
This is all temporary and we love the
fuck out of dirty bitches.
All right,
so we'll see you soon.
Oh Indianapolis this weekend.
Saturday night,
April sixth.
I'll be in Indianapolis with Tony
Hinchcliffe.
And if you've seen my live at the
Tabernacle special that's available for
five bucks on Joe Rogan Dot net right
now this set is 100 percent new.
There's nothing from that on,
on any of these shows.
So to answer all these people's
questions,
if you shoot you for June bug
dispersion,
it's all new shit.
I got an hour and 20 minutes now of all
new shit and I'm.
And I'm actually happier with it than my
last special.
So.
So can I think that,
uh,
Kevin Prayer this week,
we're going to have some good podcasts.
So if you're like freaking out needing a
podcast,
there you go.
Hinge a lot on Thursday.
Oh,
excellence.
Reggie watts tonight.
Excellence.
Yeah,
Penn Jillette.
Awesome.
That's great.
You got to do it.
He is he in town?
Uh,
yeah,
I think just he's in town one day or
something like that.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
He's a great talker too.
That guy will go on and on and on.
And I think we have cheech and Chong
next week.
Oh,
per and cheech and Chong together.
Yeah.
Interesting.
All right.
Douglas Rushkoff.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Bye.